[Music]
welcome to the reason Roundtable your
weekly podcast from the libertarian
magazine that's gonna have a webathon
next week
foreshadowing I am Matt Welch joined by
nicolesby Peter suderman and Catherine
mangu Ward Happy World Cup week
everybody
hi Matt
howdy
Happy Thanksgiving week Monday that's
what I pose like a question a little bit
there Mr suiterman we are going to get
right into it so let's get right into it
it's been uh quite the past week for our
political olds
look at look at that one sentence half a
sentence look at that that's exasperated
half a sentence you called him into it
Tuesday the 76 year old former president
Donald uh John Trump thanks Jack Johnson
undeterred by his repudiation in the
midterms uh announced that he'll once
again be escalating escalatoring into
our lives in the 2024 uh GOP
Presidential nomination round on uh
Friday uh the justice department
announced that it was appointing a
special prosecutor to look into Trump's
handling of classified documents uh and
also his role in the January 6th
unpleasantness on Thursday a couple of
82 year olds house speaker
he can't like he just can't watch him
watch him can't uh Nancy Pelosi and uh
James Clyburn who's the house Democratic
uh whip announced that they're not going
to be uh running for a reapping for
their leadership post
as uh also is the case with 83 year old
insert Nick Gillespie snort here House
Majority Leader Cindy Hoyer and then
Sunday we all celebrated as an American
uh Collective the 80th birthday of our
really existing President Joseph
Robinette Biden Jr uh as Eric fame or
bohem or whatever his name is who works
for reason and who filled in admirably
last week
wrote after Pelosi's announcement quote
America is ruled by a group of leaders
who likely would have been forced into
retirement long ago in a more normal
profession they're so old that rolling
your eyes and dismissing them as Boomers
is inaccurate
uh we are going to zoom in and out of
the individual characters referenced uh
before and the broader gerontocracy
problem but first Catherine
as someone who has been uh irrationally
uh irritated by Nancy Pelosi
your whole life I want you to uh
describe to channel
um to throw dirt on her grave one last
time but first I'm going to read you a
Joseph Biden tweet when I think of Nancy
Pelosi I think of dignity thanks history
will history will note her as the most
consequential Speaker of the House of
Representatives in history that's a good
sentence can I read it again history
will note her as the most consequential
Speaker of the House of Representatives
in history
she is first last and always for the
people America owes her a debt of
gratitude for her service patriotism and
dignity
Catherine will you finally admit that
that's true first of all just just the
the syntax of that tweet is Peak like
Grandma text right it's like the words
are duplicated if it sounds like it was
done while he was driving using voice to
text you know what I mean which is most
of the text that I receive from old
people right so uh the words that the
word that I think of when I think of
Nancy Pelosi it's actually three words
uh and it is jobs jobs jobs Matt that's
the words
um I in honor of this segment did a
search on Nancy Pelosi's website like
her house site
um and there are
70 instances
of jobs jobs jobs together 70. they
refer 70 and that's just for like the
current iteration of the site which only
seems to go back to like maybe 2010
right
um it's actually 210 instances of jobs
right that's correct yeah well sometimes
she says it four times so that wasn't
captured in the data she's mixing it up
the jobs jobs that she has created with
uh like whatever the bill is that she's
talking about at the time infrastructure
environmental regulation the Lilly
Ledbetter law she said it at John Murphy
rip rest in power in which he she quoted
him praising her for giving a speech on
the floor that was just the words what
and
she has used it for bills that contain
tax cuts she has used it for bills that
contain tax increases it's she's
insane none of these bills create
anything like the number of jobs she has
claimed for them
some of them we have the benefit of
hindsight now right like I can look back
at a bill that was passed in you know
2009 and say oh did it create the
promised four million jobs no it did not
um this is partially because politicians
don't create jobs we've talked about
that plenty of times on this podcast and
Nancy Pelosi is like the lead
spokeswoman for that delusion I think
she really believed it uh I do not think
the American people owe her a debt of
gratitude and that this is a sign of her
extremely high levels and maybe she's
just a really big fan of Steve Jobs
loves her iPhone honestly that would be
better if Nancy Pelosi 70 times over the
years have just been like you know who's
amazing Steve Jobs I would be like you
have my vote Nancy
vote in California
says you you don't even vote in other
states Peter uh what is your favorite of
uh Pelosi's uh jobs jobs bills
we all know that
um the Affordable Care Act the patient
protection and Affordable Care Act uh we
all call it Obamacare but there is an
argument to be made that it should be
called Pelosi King because it was Nancy
Pelosi who who managed the negotiation
of the details in a lot of ways and and
even more than that she was the one who
got the votes together to get it passed
and then who convinced uh President
Obama at the point that it looked like
maybe it wouldn't pass at all maybe this
whole thing was going to be a big flop
and was going to be a huge uh political
problem for Democrats uh because you
know there was this changeover in the
Senate with the Scott Brown election and
just sort of a whole big mess where the
thing stalled it had got you know the
negotiations had gone on for the better
part of a year and then like it was and
we were into the next year and it was
not at all clear that the votes were
there to be able to get this thing
passed and there were prominent
Democratic advisers to President Obama
uh prominent uh you know folks Democrats
in Congress who were especially in
private saying look look at the polling
on this health care bill it is going to
kill us let's not do nothing but let's
just scale this back do a sort of
moderate you know sort of Medicaid
expansion uh maybe you know just
something like that let's not do the big
enchilada let's not do Obamacare and it
was Pelosi who said let's do it I will
make it happen I will get the votes and
she was the one who whipped the votes uh
in into place and she was the one who
convinced President Obama that it that
it could be done when when the
conventional wisdom was that it could
not be and if you looked back to that
time the early months of 2010 before
final passage it was really very unclear
and so in one way it is a story of how
uh how brutally effective she was as a
leader she was somebody who could put a
vote together and get the votes for
something that wasn't obviously going to
be popular in another way it's obviously
a story of someone who pushed through
legislation that has uh I think not
worked out very well to the point where
when President Obama looked back at it
uh recently he was basically like well
you know it was good except it didn't do
the things that it was supposed to do
and now we have to build on it so that
we'll finally do the things it was
supposed to do originally and you know
it's also worth noting that if you go
back to the 2010 mid sure which is it
was was the next election after
Democrats passed Obamacare Democrats
lost uh lost control of the house and
there was pretty good social science
research indicating that Obamacare was
the sole reason now there were a bunch
of reasons why Democrats you know sort
of lost votes but that Obamacare alone
cost them uh something like 25 or 30
seats and that was why they lost control
of the house and so in some ways you
know Nancy Pelosi made an argument uh
and got made an argument to her members
and got her members to vote for
something that was against their
short-term political interests Nick will
you not rise to defend
the outgoing house Speaker yeah I want
to point out that you know in all of the
hullabaloo about her being the first
female Speaker of the House
uh they short-sheeted the fact that
she's the only Italian-American speaker
oh okay and uh you know come on at least
at least out non closet yeah I mean a
lot of them are passing they use these
Anglo-Saxon names people like Kevin
McCarthy I think he you know he's pretty
smarty
um
uh for me two things about Pelosi one is
that uh when she campaigned or in the in
the 2008
um elections in uh 2000 yeah I guess
2006
um elections she was putting together a
package for the Democrats to be the
fiscally responsible party she talked a
lot about that and it was really great
because we were coming off of six years
of uh total profligacy by the the Bush
Administration and the Empower
Republicans and she talked quite openly
and explicitly about how the Democratic
party was the party of fiscal
responsibility and they were going to
reign in out of control spending on both
domestic and Foreign Affairs and things
like that and she lasted about a month
and a half and then caved and started
you know handing out pork uh because it
was seen at the time that the reason the
Democrats won the house uh was because
of rural Farm votes that had flipped to
Democrats and things like that and it
was uh a really shameful moment because
that that could have been a moment where
we you know as a uh in a consensual way
uh or a bipartisan way the uh the uh
government actually moved to reign in
out of control spending and it really
just didn't happen so shame on her for
that and everything that's come since
then uh the one thing I will say about
her in her defense uh besides the fact
that it did take her 72 hours but she
did eventually get up off the floor
after kneeling while wearing kenty cloth
along with the other 80 year olds in
Congress I think a couple of them
Clyburn I don't know if he ever fully
got up again or they just kind of slid
him off to the side
but um
um she really did have in AOC and the
squad and the most extreme progressives
in the Democratic caucus and I don't
think the next person is going to be
able to do that on the Democratic side
and we are we already know I mean if if
we're framing this as gerontocracy
versus vibrant middle age or something
Kevin McCarthy who's likely to be the
speaker is 57 as minority leader he
could not keep Marjory Taylor Green's
Yap shut
um and he's also a whipping boy he's a
pool boy for Donald Trump we're gonna go
we're gonna I think we're gonna see very
quickly the difference between a speaker
of the house who actually is an
effective leader and somebody who is a
complete [ __ ] doormat for all of the
worst elements of their party
um so you know that will actually make
us perhaps Miss uh Nancy Pelosi a little
bit there's this narrative
I just want to note that except for in
very very specific situations The
Whipping Boy and the pool boy are
different it depends on the Kink I mean
I watched the Jerry Falwell uh junior uh
yeah I said that yeah there's a there's
a couple of links there is this
narrative out there that she has been
anti-progressive that I think is
basically correct because of the way
that she like you said Nick the way that
she is hemmed in AOC and the squad there
was that great cutting remark that she
made a couple of years ago where she
referred to the green new deal as the
green dream or whatever at the same time
I think if you look at her record it is
a record of pushing Congress pushing the
Democratic Party in the direction of big
government liberalism it is not it is
not a moderate Democratic record it is
just one that has resisted the most
extreme Progressive impulses
which is not anything I agree with you
and you know a couple years ago at an
NYU uh event or something she told this
student who was like why aren't we
getting single-payer Health Care why are
we getting socialized health care and
she was like Hey Democrats or
capitalists get over it
um so you know it may be that she is uh
as much as anything of Bellwether of how
far government and particularly on the
Democratic side it's listing towards
just this you know kind of katulu-like
massive expansive blob that is just you
know moving away from Market forces my
favorite thing about Nancy Pelosi is
just her kind of slightly off uncanny
valley uh attempt at having human
reactions to things
um if you don't follow Kyle Dunnigan as
a comedian on Youtube I I recommend that
you do
um does all kinds of crazy
impersonations and this Pelosi
impersonation captures that uh
particularly well but my uh Iran random
moment plucked out of The Ether came
from the 2016 campaign there was a
moment in September of that year where
Gary Johnson was polling libertarian
party nominee was uh polling around 10
percent and he's sort of heading into uh
uh possibly on the debate stage
so Democrats went all out spent a lot of
money uh trying to trash him and as part
of that during the rollout of this Nancy
Pelosi said do you think most people who
have said they're going to be for the
libertarian because they like his
hairstyle or whatever it is are going to
stick with that
like the idea that people wanted Gary
Johnson because his hairstyle
it just
Pelosi and Biden are cut weirdly from
the same Santa Claus cloth and it's
it's
um but yeah they have they do have it's
not that stretchy Lululemon stuff is it
no the kids these days wear that Nancy
would never but the you know this little
this little teeny bit of like maybe
they're just gonna say his hair or
whatever maybe they're gonna see say
green dream maybe they're gonna say corn
pop that like unfortunately the impulse
to like to kind of appreciate that and
vote for people and support politicians
who are like that in its extreme version
just get to Donald Trump right but
people are more likely to be like that
the older they get like this is at least
one it's a small part but like this is
one part of like why we are
absolutely struggling under a
giantocracy is because old people just
say stuff and Americans like it when
their politicians just say stuff
sometimes they like a gaff they love a
gaff that is how we got Joe Biden as
president
in a weird way I think that's how Nancy
held on so long and they don't you know
that's why people don't like you know
Pete bootage or something they don't
like the sort of super disciplined
person with their wits about them I was
just trying to fancy frame but but when
you get down to it it's like people
don't like poop to judge because he has
nothing of interest to say
right and I don't think people are maybe
I'm not sure that's it Nancy Pelosi
doesn't have anything interesting that
doesn't know that was the last time you
were like oh my good young people I was
thinking when we were talking we're
going to be talking about gerontocracy
you know Conrad adnauer was like a
thousand years old and when he led West
Germany after World War II and he was
the guy who I uh you know he was the guy
who put together the German Miracle
because he could remember the past and
he had you know uh objected to the Nazis
and he you know he had like five minutes
of strength left in his body and he put
them on the right course so it's not
necessarily age per se versus youth or
anything like that I saw a great
documentary where they showed him
playing Bocce or the German version of
bocce and it was like Mr Burns punching
somebody like it the ball like fell on
his toes but he couldn't feel them so it
was okay but you know age age is a
problem we need to get rid of the
gerontocracy but we also need to develop
better younger leaders because they suck
and I would argue at this point that's
the reason why we have these old [ __ ]
in place is because people like Kevin
you know and the Young Guns they suck
um you know like nobody knew is coming
up who can actually push these old old
people you know in their wheelchairs off
the cliff you're not disappointed by Tom
Cotton's announcement that he's not
running for president I've
broken-hearted we always broken-hearted
I'm wearing black uh the uh one of my
favorite emergent themes on this podcast
uh over the over the years is NYX
increasing the kids these days aren't
good for nothing theme which like I know
you just said we need to get rid of the
gerontocracy but you just don't believe
that
you know if you're 40 years old and you
can't take Nancy Pelosi you don't
deserve it's like the ending of the
first Black Panther movie like if you
can't beat her on that pool on the you
know on the top of a cliff you don't
deserve to be Speaker of the House I I
think shots were fired across the bow of
Peter suderman there Peter is there
something
structural about the way Congress does
its business that leads to uh this
so-called gerontocracy yeah I mean I
think if Congress weren't deciding
leadership based on a battle in front of
a like green screen pool between two
like rival you know leaders of wakanda
obviously we would have better leaders
younger leaders because that's that's I
think that was the upshot of what Nick
said now it's the two-party system it's
the it's actually it is it's the the
that that like it is the it is the fact
that we just have two parties battling
each other uh except not in front of the
the bad green screen water effects
it's the fact that we only have two
parties and that American politics is
organized around Republicans and
Democrats each trying to get to 51
percent
um that empowers older leaders who have
experience already rather than a
multi-party system like you have in
Europe which is why Europe is has many
problems as in some ways more liberal
than the United States but they are not
suffering under a gerontocracy in the
same way because they have a bunch of a
bunch of different parties that allow
for younger leaders to get into politics
uh early it also they offer things that
young people might want out of politics
right they're sort of more able to
Target their messages to people under
40. and so what that does is it creates
more political experience within you
know amongst people who are not yet you
know seven years old and so what we have
right now is a system in which it takes
a long time to work your way up to the
top of a party and to build that kind of
experience and it is relatively hostile
to newcomers so it's so Obama you know
is is in some ways an outlier here
whereas Joe Biden and Donald Trump
um and Nancy Pelosi and the rest of the
Democratic Leadership team are are not
right I mean the it's it is a it is a
a result of of the two-party system uh
in some ways that we have that we have
leaders who are so old um and who are so
entrenched in power
but wait I mean I don't think that makes
sense because we had Clinton Bush and
Obama who were all extremely young there
was a generational change and I think
one is coming and this is the last gasp
of the baby boom even if most of the
people we're talking about are actually
pre-baby Boomers I think it's a cyclical
thing but if it was simply two parties
we would have had a giantocracy earlier
I I think it gets more complicated than
that and part of it is that you know at
the same time that primaries are more
important than ever and you tend to
nominate extreme people in in primaries
the parties have also lost control of
main messaging
um I mean I just think there's a lot of
different things going on here and that
it can't simply be the primary system
definitely drives people drives parties
towards extremism right towards more uh
sort of candidates that appeal more
the parties are less in control of what
candidates get picked than probably ever
in history
um and so you get these extreme people
and maybe it's that on the fringes you
get you know the Marjorie teller greens
and the aocs and that actually then
creates within the caucus a desire for a
more Centrist leadership or something I
don't know but you know I don't know how
you explain going from Clinton and
Gingrich in the 90s who were young they
were baby boomers very you know very
Peak Baby Boomers and you know we are
going to change the world we're taking
over from these old farts to they are
now you know people older than them are
in power I don't know if you saw this
tweet going around I think it's from an
Iowa uh University law professor but the
winners of the past I don't know
eight nine ten presidential elections
here are their uh birth dates in order
beginning in 1992.
1946 Bill Clinton 1946
Bill Clinton
1946 George W bush 1946 George W bush I
had 1961 twice for Obama then
1946. Donald Trump and now 1942.
Joe Biden what was in 30 years the water
in 1946.
yeah I was gonna say like probably
sometimes
fluoride fluoride right it's a baby when
it all went downhill there's a baby one
so I guess uh a lot of uh the uh covid
Baby Boom is going to produce the next
round of uh of presents uh fun fact no
president ever born in the 1930s or the
1950s or the 1960s okay just throwing
that out there uh Obama you just listen
to him as 1960. whatever
um the 61 of the 60s so I'm beginning
it's like how in the movies the the
1980s actually begin with alien in 1979
just like that yep yeah
uh Joe uh Joe Biden
um this was a fun uh headline in a New
York Times piece about his age
um a couple days ago
President Biden is turning 80. experts
say age is more than a number
I think I is that sponsored uh content
by depends or something yeah Cialis uh I
uh I think that that I'm just guessing
that headline would have read a little
bit different if there was actually a
red wave instead of a a red trickle red
uh uh
fill in the blank something a red snort
exasperated sign from Nick Gillespie
um uh yeah it's a it's I mean I think
Biden would have had a lot of pressure
to exit the race and to announce that
he's not running for re-election and now
he's in this awkward thing ah they won
it's a mandate here we go
um uh uh with us uh he has no idea where
he is it just he thinks he's in a
Twilight Zone episode
uh
and who's to say he's not Catherine is
there any benefit of having uh
daughtering old geezer who experts say
age is more than a number as president
yeah
I mean I'm if I'm trying to be like I'm
doing the thought exercise right like
I'm trying to be charitable and I think
that the best answer to that is you know
he's seen some stuff like if you're born
in 19
40 whatever like all these guys
they have they know what crashed and
burned and I do think that that's
valuable now I think that like there's a
the curve for acquiring that kind of
here's how the world Works here's how
politics Works knowledge it it you know
it's it slopes up and then it kind of
flattens out right like the difference
between the here's how the world Works
here's how the world Works knowledge of
an 80 year old and like a 60 year old
maybe not substantially different but I
do think there is a case for don't put
the very very young in charge now very
very young in American politics is still
not very young right I mean we are
founders in their Infinite Wisdom put
some floors on the ages at which you
could serve in various bodies but it's I
know a lot of people in their 80s
and I think most of them would say
I wouldn't be a good president like not
all of them and clearly at least one of
them is out here saying he would be a
good president but you know as someone
who recently has like slowed down due to
bodily malfunction
like my brain isn't as good because my
knee hurts and I think like everyone
who's 80 their knee hurts all the time
like or some part of them
and that really shouldn't be discounted
like there is there is clearly something
about being like at or near sort of good
physical health that helps you be a good
decision maker you know you have to be
able to be at least see the top of your
form in the distance Joe Biden
absolutely does not have that and again
I think it would be one thing if there
was a single outlier but the whole
system being run by 80 year olds or
seven-year-olds means that they are not
they're not good at getting reality
checks right they're all sitting around
being old together and being like we're
fine
um and they're just like they're not
totally fine and I I refuse to believe
that any of these people are so
spectacularly better at their jobs as
individuals that the slowing down of
Ages irrelevant because that's the other
thing it's basically the hubris of
politicians you know yes I'm not you
know not as sharp as I once was but I am
still so much better than anyone else
who wants this job that I am justified
in keeping it that is not the case it is
simply untrue that the people who
currently happen to hold power are
unique special snowflakes
so what American politics really needs
is better lumbar support pillows
honestly maybe I don't know I'm out here
definitely in favor of a better
Orthopedic cushions these days um Peter
one of the lines from Eric bohem's uh
piece uh was that the average American
is now a full two decades younger than
the average member of Congress who at
age 59 is a full two decades younger
than the president and outgoing speaker
of the house
um following up on Catherine's Point
what is there a practical import of that
in terms of governance that that's
negative just besides having people who
always have to have their comments
walked back by their own press office is
there something in policy that uh is
worse than it would be because of that
uh dynamic
so the answer is yes but before we get
to that maybe we should point out the
one good thing about all of this which
is that it does uh reflect the fact that
Americans are living longer and
healthier lives and that that people are
staying like at the at the top yes I
mean like in in general
um people are people are saying it has
been pretty bad okay the last couple of
years uh you know notwithstanding like
overall life spans are longer and in
particular people are staying active
mentally engaged fit able to do things
much later into life this is why we see
uh this is why we see actors and even in
action movies are getting much much
older this is why uh you know Disney
just uh reinstalled their previous
president Bob
um after two years of a different
president Bob uh the the kovid Bob got
basically got pushed out in a pretty
bizarre thing for a 71 year old because
the 71 year old the the old 71 year old
who had quit who had said he was out is
it you know he's like bored he's writing
a book and he's like he's still smart
and he's still the person that uh the
Disney board thinks is going to be the
most effective person in what they
expect to be a trying economic time so
there's a bunch of good news here it is
sort of built into our conversation
about the gerontocracy uh just in terms
of lifespans and and capabilities at the
same time the fact that we are ruled
politically by people who are
substantially older than the average
American right so it's not just that uh
that you know the average American
they're they're not reflecting the
average American in their ages and what
that means is they are making policy in
a lot of ways or they are more inclined
to make policy that benefits older
people which is part of the reason we
have such a staunch defense of the uh of
the entitlement State and the
entitlement system which is primarily
about funneling a huge amount of money
to seniors and seniors are at this point
in time a relatively wealthy group
compared to other age cohorts and we
spend a huge huge amount of money in the
federal budget just goes to Social
Security and Medicare and not just a
huge amount that like well that's a lot
it's a huge amount that we can't afford
because as I say on this podcast just
about every single week sometime in the
next 10 or 15 years both of those
programs are going to have major trust
funds go insolvent and not be able to
pay their bills and the only thing that
anybody is really saying about that is
well we're going to protect those
programs
and I guess and the other side won't
but they're not really providing plans
for us I also know I mean
we have told our share of series of
tubes jokes uh over the years but I do
think it's also relevant that one of the
most important questions that Congress
is going to have to deal with in the
next few years is internet regulation
and the regulation of online speech and
again
there are outliers but of the
septuagenarians and oxygenarians that I
know they are not very clear on what is
going on online like they have bits and
pieces they have advisors in the form of
either their Congressional staff or like
their grandkids who are filling them in
on some of it but
truly it does not make sense to have
people who are so much older than the
American public who are using the
internet in such anomalous way we need
more legislators on Tick Tock make the
rules for the internet that's a bad idea
that's gonna happen would you rather be
governed by AOC or by Mitch McConnell I
refuse to believe that those are the
only two options but those are I mean
that's I I mean I think you're just
talking about talking about age simply
is is the wrong way to go about this
um because there are older people who
are quite Adept and knowledgeable and
can bring the wisdom of the ages the
wisdom of kutulu-like ancient
understanding of the past a double and
there are a lot of young people and
there are a lot of younger people who
are complete idiots about everything uh
and I think the real problem and it
might be it's easier to probably to
track this as gerontocracy and I'm I'm
sick of it Mitch McConnell is 80.
um it's interesting that he tends not to
come up in these discussions of you know
old farts running everything he's a
problem I think from a Libertarian
perspective he's as much of a problem as
Nancy Pelosi or anybody else but you
know it isn't simply age it's you know
the quality of legislation or the lack
thereof and that's I think where we
would do best to focus uh most of our I
do think at the
yeah I mean you've definitely just like
set fire to that straw man like I just
don't think anybody is saying it's only
you were just you were just saying that
you were just saying that old people
don't understand new technology so they
shouldn't be in charge I said
I don't think that's true I don't think
that's true at all I think young people
who have no understanding of what the
FCC did you know or or what the phone
company Monopoly was like necessarily
have the wherewithal to actually govern
something like the internet
um or or don't remember the fact that
the great thing about the internet is
that it was ungovernable you know and
that was like you know John Perry Barlow
and other people who were stupid hippies
in a lot of ways were [ __ ] great
because they were like no this is a new
place and you don't get this at the
rules I think we need more of that and I
I just I think the question is whether
you have a bias towards Innovation and
towards Freedom uh when it comes to new
technology or whether you have a bias
towards Nostalgia and sort of steady
state uh requirements right like
demanding that that things be locked in
place and it's obviously true that some
young people want things to be locked in
place and they hate Innovation and they
hate Freedom at the margins however I
think if you are older you are more
likely to be against to be to be biased
towards Nostalgia and to be biased
towards well I want things to be the way
they always have been rather than I
think the future is going to be
interesting because people who are older
have less future in front of them all
right speaking I agree uh you know we
should always be looking towards people
who are interested in Innovation and
change and and optimism I don't know
that age is in any way of meaningful uh
indicator of that in politics okay let's
stop talking about this now
um we're gonna get to our listener email
of the week here in a moment uh as well
as yet another webathon tease
But first you might think you've done
everything in your power to ensure your
family in the case of a medical
emergency but what many of us don't
realize is that health insurance alone
won't always cover the full cost of for
example an emergency medical flight if
you require Air transport even
comprehensive coverage can leave you
with high deductibles and co-pays that's
where air Med Care Network comes in when
you sign up to become a member of The
airmed Care Network should any such
emergency arise you will not see a bill
for air Medical Transport when flown by
a provider airmed care transports more
than 100 000 patients each and every
year that's about one every five minutes
this peace of mind for you and your
whole family can be yours beginning at
the low low price of just 85 a year
let's search the round table can get
gift cards with their new memberships
for up to fifty dollars through either
Visa or Amazon simply visit
airmedcarenetwork.com reason and use the
offer code reason and start protecting
your family do it today you'll be glad
you're dead come on all right remember
reminder to send us your succinct emails
to Roundtable at reason.com and check it
on out next week we are launching our
annual webathon fundraising drive it's
more of a fun raising Drive uh and as
part of that we will be doing uh our
bonus uh ask me anything ask us anything
episode of the reason Roundtable so this
is the time to start collecting hunting
Gathering and shooting off emptying your
holsters of uh questions uh uh putting
us on the spot could be individual could
be the group uh about uh about us about
reasoning about Libertarians uh whatever
is on your mind
um this week's email comes uh from
Dorothy Parker
I I I'm not I'm not sure that's her real
name but Dorothy Parker writes hi
friends
I like weed
[Laughter]
I think all the emails should start off
with with three word Declarations of
what you like I like weed marijuana is a
wonderful drug I don't know why we keep
looking for female Viagra when it
already exists and I celebrate recent
expansions of legalization there are
risks just as there are with any drug
and there is a potential for abuse
nonetheless if you compare the damage
done by weed with the Damage Done by the
War on Drugs it's not even close amen
unsurprisingly I've noted an uptick in
news items describing the dangers of
marijuana yesterday the wsj that's Wall
Street Journal declared marijuana may
hurt smokers more than cigarettes alone
the conclusion was based on the study of
a whopping six marijuana only smokers
this news Trend makes me nervous what
attacks can we expect now that
legalization is spreading I'm thinking
flimsy studies to convince everyone it's
a major health risk from the left and
stories about psychosis from the right
what do you think is the next move
against illegal marijuana and how can we
anticipate it Nick you're stoned right
now why don't you leave us off tripping
balls man
uh yeah I think we're going to see more
and more of this kind of stuff and it's
uh very quickly going to morph out of
marijuana into the realm of psychedelics
and other more potent esoteric and kind
of uh nervous making uh substances
um I will link to a couple of pieces
that might show up in the uh the show
notes about how on the left people are
upset that right-wingers are interested
in psychedelics to treat things like
post-traumatic stress disorder and other
kinds of trauma-related problems and on
the right uh everybody's talking about
how mushrooms are terrible and it's it's
kind of a way for the left to bedazzle
people and get them to sign on to
Turning every uh County Fair into a
burning a regional Burning Man event
um this is something I don't think the
drug legalization movement which has
been moving forward with very little
backlash I mean you know we've been
driving towards Baghdad with very little
pushback
um and it's gonna as it gets closer and
closer to actually being a thing where
marijuana is recognized at the national
level and the international level and
other other drugs start being treated to
you know legalization
based on cost-benefit analyzes as well
as kind of calculations of whether or
not a free Society should allow people
to choose their own intoxicants and you
know use them responsibly or not there's
going to be a massive pushback so you
see that the other thing I'll say is the
one thing that's going to be interesting
is I predict that most of the back lash
is not going to come from traditional
right-wing sources you know it's not
going to be National Review that is
leading the charge against this stuff
it's going to be Center left
Publications like the Atlantic and New
York Magazine New York Magazine over the
summer uh had a podcast as well as a
story about the dangers of ketamine
addiction and whatnot you're going to
see a lot of people who are Center left
who are just freaked out by drugs
because they're very establishmentarian
and they're very stayed and square in
their lives even if they pretend to be
be kind of hip and cool and things like
that so that's the place to look the
center left for the uh you know The
Cutting Edge of the anti-drug
legalization movement
Catherine you are the caretaker of this
fine magazine and therefore have read
and edited
50
four years worth of arguments about
Prohibition uh by prohibitionists
themselves what do you uh see as a as a
uh upcoming move by resurgent
prohibitionists in the face of freedom
I think we are going to see that despite
having lived through an actual real
honest to God pandemic that the CDC will
not be learning its lesson and that we
will be subject to
a tremendous and tremendously expensive
public health campaign about the dangers
of marijuana use I think that yes
there's going to be
um scare stories in the media and that
kind of thing I think to some extent
like fine everybody have at it right
your scare stories you know I I think
they're largely ungrounded but so be it
the place that I think is more dangerous
is when we have
um we have an entity like the CDC which
is increasingly empowered to run little
chunks of the economy and guide U.S
policy
they're gonna they're gonna do what they
did for Vaping they're gonna do what
they did for obesity I think actually
the closest model to the way that we're
gonna see marijuana treated in the near
future is going to be soda like remember
in the 90s when like buying a really big
coke was a threat to the Republic
that's kind of where we're going to be
assuming it gets legalized which I think
it will at the federal level
we will then have this immediate kind of
you know the federal government giveth
and the federal government taketh away
as the CDC slowly and loudly loses its
mind about
all the downsides of marijuana
consumption which are sometimes real
right like I don't I don't mean to say
just like drinking a gigantic Coke is
every single day of your life is
probably not a good idea there are real
downsides to marijuana use
they will be blown out of proportion by
an entity funded by taxpayer dollars
Peter what have you to add to this
conversation I think that from the right
we will mostly see politically expedient
attacks linking legal weed to Crime Tom
Cotton among others Matt's favorite
young politician is already linking
marijuana pardons to fears of rising
crime in advance of the midterm this
year and from the left I think we're
going to see a different kind of
pushback that's going to be focused on
sales and profits and worries about big
weed and if you look at in even in the
the legalization movement sort of a
bunch of the expert class that
identifies as you know sort of left or
Center left has for years said well of
course we shouldn't be arresting people
for smoking pot on the other hand we
definitely shouldn't let anyone sell it
and make a lot of money and there's a
real tension there and I think that we
are now we are going to see you know
some allowance
um for for uh for say sales and for
profit making but it's but there will be
a lot of attempts to limit it and along
with those attempts to limit profit
making they're gonna attempt to restrict
new products and they're going to say oh
wait
you can only sell this kind of joint
that's regulated in this kind of way or
brownies that are you know five
milligrams and no more and there's just
going to be all of this sort of
bureaucratic red tape associated with
being in the weed business and that is
mostly going to come from the left
except of course when the left brings on
allies on the right who are just trying
to use that to stop weed sales and to
stop it from growing my prediction is
not a prediction it's a description of
the reality around me here in Brooklyn
New York which is to say there's uh some
kind of conflation or intersection is
better uh between vaping uh kids and
weed uh and also the sense and reality
of public disorder that is going to
absolutely generate changes in policy or
public attitudes at least on a local
level uh what I mean is that vaping has
all kinds of strange it's a gray Market
everywhere and it's also a cash Market
as as a result of its grayness and so
from Cops who I'm conversant with in New
York they say well you know kids and
also gangs know uh where to have an easy
little Heist is of the money hanging
around vape stores which are everywhere
all the bodegas are vape stores now it's
it's amazing the conversion of so much
just nor sort of Street retail into
vaping and also you smell pot uh
everywhere and oftentimes you smell pot
because you see uh teenagers who are
clearly underage uh just vaping weed uh
in public which is something you just
did not see it park right around across
the street from me um has had this for a
while and everybody in the neighborhood
is talking about it and like somewhat
freaked out about it this is easier to
notice in a big city than it is in other
places
um but I think you will start to see
people making uh conversations about you
know a 16 year old's brain gets warped
their their growth gets done haunted if
they smoke pot and it leads to all kinds
of other kinds of things and it's it's
going to be part of the ongoing and like
uh measurable uh in terms of politics
backlash against uh
um you know the small tiptoeing criminal
justice reforms in New York
um in the face of perceived disorder and
Rising crime it'll definitely be part of
that so wherever there is uh
legalization regime that has led to kind
of kids openly flouting what used to be
uh uh enforced laws
um you're going to see a I think a
political and policy backlash is mine
one of the uh things Matt about New York
that is unique in particular is uh that
it's legal to smoke weed in the open uh
which other states did not do when they
passed legalization uh if you watch New
York over the next six to eight 12
months when the retail rules come out
and the licenses for retail shops which
have been taking forever because of a
lot of stupid politics when those come
out and had New York in this sense even
though it took forever to legalize weed
that framework May well kind of tell the
future of the story because there's
everything you're talking about is
absolutely true and it's legal because
you can smoke weed legally in New York
which is why you smell it more here than
you do in LA or in DC or in Colorado or
Washington State all right we've been
talking about uh old people running for
president doing other kind of stuff we
haven't really talked about uh Donald
Trump he had a busy week last week we
don't have a ton of time to talk about
it so we should kind of Go Lightning
roundish he as I said before announces
candidacy for president there's been a
lot of people who used to be as allies
used to be as whipping boys not pool
boys like Paul Ryan but also Mike Pompeo
uh Mike Pence just everybody named Mike
um uh has been coming out and saying
okay it's enough is enough Chris
Christie gave a big speech
um and so there's the battle lines are
being uh I mean Chris Christie and big
in a sentence
um the battle Line's being drawn Etc you
guys were here for it I was out of the
country
um what do you make I find that very uh
interesting yeah we're out of the
country yep uh what do you uh make of
Trump's big last week even in the face
of getting his hat handed to him by
extension in the midterms Catherine
wanted to lead us off with our uh
putative would-be
jiren to krat in Chief yeah I guess my
lightning round thought is
um this idea that somehow the results of
the midterms might determine what Trump
was going to do is just the latest in a
series of delusions on the part of the
uh political chattering class that this
one this thing this is the thing that's
going to finally
eliminate Donald Trump from our politics
there is no thing he will not be
eliminated he will be in our politics he
will be our politics uh so I guess uh
you know just more of Sam he's back
we're gonna do this again
um Nick how do you solve a problem like
Donald Trump in this in the following
sense uh even if he is no longer uh able
to get 47 of the electorate to support
him he could probably get 40 now or you
know 35 but those 35 are with him
um uh what does that say what does that
uh uh uh worry you about uh in the
immediate future for the Republican
party for the country well yeah I
obviously I don't really care about the
future of the Republican party uh except
as it impacts my future and everybody on
this podcast future and good reason
readers and whatnot
um I interviewed Robert Draper the New
York Times uh writer whose new book is
called Weapons of Mass delusion our
interview will be coming out I think
next week
um he makes a very Salient point about
Donald Trump's followers is that they
have never been particularly popular
within the Republican Party they've
never been a majority so it doesn't
matter you're exactly right Matt that
this is a hardcore band of kind of like
you know suicide gurkhas they don't
[ __ ] care
um and Trump's support within the party
could be 25 and they are still going to
light everything on fire so I think
Catherine's right he's not going away
and I think that there's a you know when
you look at people like Kevin McCarthy
you know who represents kind of now the
establishment of the party he is
terrified of trump he has shown over the
past several years that he will do
anything to Curry favor or or not get
too in touch with Trump I think what you
see is a Republican party that is too
afraid of Donald Trump to decisively
move to shun him even even if it seems
to be electorally powerful I think the
uh what what Donald Trump's actual
genius was is showing that the
Republican party has no principles left
that it is willing to stand by and fight
for
um and as a result they will go down
with Trump until he finally gives up The
Ghost and what that means I don't know
but um I think Trump is in it and he
will drag the Republicans down with him
and more importantly he will drag down
political discourse I don't think the
Democrats are going to be offering any
kind of good alternative or anything but
like Trump to the extent that is he he
is pulling the one party that in the
past has shown some libertarian
sensibilities towards an open Society
towards borders and open economy on
things like that you know it's it's
really not good
Peter what's your uh terse take on
Trump's uh eventful week
you know how people sometimes retweet a
tweet just like any tweet
and then they just add I am so tired
I am so tired
do the work I think Nick's Nick's right
like the way to defeat him is to defeat
him and a big question is whether he's
going to face a big divided field like
you did in 2016 or whether he will face
a single clear rival likely Ron DeSantis
um here and I just think that the the
current state of the Republican Party
the Trump entry really shows that the
GOP does not have a strong center of
gravity there's no strong leadership
there no sort of even clear clear
ideological Direction
um and Trump has exploited that
um he's the closest thing there is to a
center of gravity there but he's
actually relatively weak as a leader and
he's always been weak right he won the
Primary in 2016 in part because of the
big crowded field and he beat Hillary
Clinton in part because people really
really really hated Hillary Clinton and
were tired of the clintons Stranglehold
on the Democratic Party politics and
National politics and so to me you know
the the sort of the the question here
is whether Trump is going to be able to
exploit a weak field again or not and I
don't know the answer there's already a
bunch of reports about a bunch of people
kind of who are who are going to try and
jump in and and beat him um and I think
that that could end up being maybe not
the best thing for the Republican party
or at least a Republican party that
wants to be Trump
all right um let's get to our end of
podcast what we have been consuming in
the artistic and cultural uh sphere uh
Catherine wanted to lead us off
I read the novel light from uncommon
Stars by Rika Aoki it was recommended by
our listeners I'm still working through
those wrecks and so I appreciate it
um it's pretty good it's a book about
violin virtuosos and space travel and
pandemics and donuts and the devil
it's good and uh it's one of these books
that you spend a little bit longer than
is perhaps ideal uh disoriented you know
in those first a few pages and then uh
once you're in it you're in it it has
the uh the same Vibes as everything
everywhere all at once uh so if you
liked that movie everything everywhere
did I say that right if you like that
movie uh you would probably like this
book
um I enjoyed it quite a lot light from
uncommon Stars Nick Gillespie what have
you consumed yeah my uh conception was
on the Roku Channel a weird the Al
Yankovic story uh oh fake biopic uh
directed by Eric Appel
um who has a bunch of roots in Funny or
Die
um this uh stars to add a Radcliffe uh
you know Harry Potter as Weird Al and it
is a phenomenal movie highly highly
recommended both I love the movie itself
and the fact that it's on the Roku
Channel which is you know just another
sign that we have reached a
proliferation of cultural Source I mean
there's so much great stuff out there
coming at you from every direction I'll
just focus on there's one scene where uh
Rayne Wilson the guy from The Office
plays Dr Demento who is kind of Weird Al
Yankovic's mentor and he's having a
barbecue uh and it's a bunch of
celebrities there including Conan
O'Brien plays Andy Warhol in a
tremendous turn of events Weird Al
Yankovic is in this movie as one of the
Scotty Brothers which is the shitty
record label that produced uh that
released a bunch of Weird Al's early
records and things like that but Jack
Black shows up as Wolfman Jack and this
scene is as funny as anything that has
been committed to video or film in the
past 50 years highly highly recommend
we're the Al Yankovic story and it is
great because it has no bearing on
reality whatsoever past present or
future and ends with one of the greatest
endings of any fake biopic of all time
just highly recommend it get a Roku
stick or sign up for the Roku Channel
whatever you have to do watch weird the
the Alia uh weird the Al Yankovic sorry
uh that I can't wait uh to watch it
someone who grew up listening to Dr
Demento I remember when Al Yankovic was
like making his uh his great debut along
with uh it's so good and Weird Al is one
of the I mean he is a true genius whose
career you know is like in its fifth
decade now or something is he's like
lasted longer than virtually any single
person he parody he's the upside of the
gerontocracy
he yeah you know he I mean it's like
getting still going strong as this movie
shows it's like really really good uh
fun fact uh uh who uh among uh reasons
most uh uh beloved uh and long uh
Service long-serving gerontocracy uh
staff is a huge uh Yankovic fan
it all comes together uh Peter suderman
what have you consumed I have been
reading the giant lavish coffee table
book
kempari and the cinema you know what
it's about
it's about Campari and the cinema so
Campari of course is the Italian red
bitter liqueur that is a or maybe even
arguably the essential ingredient in a
Negroni or a boulevardier as well as
many popular variations in offshoots uh
and Campari has a long history of
intersection with the movies including
like a 1984 TV commercial that you can
watch on YouTube directed by Fellini by
Fellini the guy who directed eight and a
half one of the great movies about
movies uh there's also like a recent
short film uh starring Clive Owen is
like maybe a murderer or bartender or
something there's a lot of negronis
involved um uh also incidentally there's
a whole scene built around negronis in
the most in the recent Uncharted film
starring that it's a video game
adaptation starring Tom Holland and
Marky Mark Wahlberg in which Tom Holland
plays a bartender who is also sort of an
Indiana Jones kind of Adventurer and at
one point he gives a history of the
Negroni a history that is sort of has
been widely accepted but is in in
dispute these days amongst cocktail
historians who now believe that it
wasn't count Negroni who invented it but
that the drink was actually invented in
Africa anyway as a fan of both movies
and negronis I'm really enjoying the
book it's a great celebration of two
things I love
so I spent last week on a junket in
Israel
the Holy Land uh which I'd never been to
never been to the Middle East uh
completely uh ignorant of such things
and so had a pretty wonderful time and
saw a lot of of various things one I
will recommend
um partly because I had no idea that it
existed and if you find yourself in
Israel which I do recommend people
travel to it's pretty amazing to see the
such history if nothing else
um is a an archaeological site called
city of David it's
um so Jerusalem sort of famously has an
old city it's up on a hill
um which is obviously described as a
mountain back then because they didn't
know
um and uh it's got walls and such and uh
but uh since the place has been
inhabited forever and just constantly
ransacked and besieged and and crusaded
and God knows what uh literally
um for a long time uh the people just
keep building on top of whatever they
just recently destroyed and so when the
Brits controlled British Palestine
they wanted to do some digging see what
was underneath all of it and there was
an archaeologist who was looking at the
Bible and uh the Old Testament and
noticing that the physical descriptions
didn't make that much sense of just
where the the hills were located the
mountains and the river and there's a a
key scene where David
you know David
um like crawls up a water a shoot of
some sort of water tunnel and it didn't
it wouldn't make sense to be in the old
walled City and so they started digging
in what is East Jerusalem uh 120 some
odd years ago
and started
um the discovering things old walls um
and and developed the thesis that
um here was the uh actual site of the
original city of Jerusalem as described
in the Old Testament in the ancient
Hebrew stuff
um there wasn't a lot of digging that
happened until uh recently that's the
kind of crazy thing
um it's East it's East Jerusalem so
Israel only uh gets control over it
after the Six Day War in 1967. and so
it's an ongoing dig and uh it's just
kind of spectacular to go you get to
um go and stand on what is the highest
ground
of that area where they've kind of now
remapped out where the old walled City
used to be and it's again not where the
current one is and
um you know with the tour guide you flip
open and you read a Psalm written by
David like actually wrote it uh and he's
describing physically what you're
looking at
um and the vantage point of what you're
looking at
um they have found uh and it's it's a
controversial site as everything is
controversial in
um in Israel in general in Jerusalem
specifically
um people are uh uh there's disputes
over how much they're kind of trying to
do wish fulfillment archeology for the
state of Israel for Judaism
um and an interesting part of it is that
uh Christians are all in too if you go
online and like do a YouTube search of
city of David you'll find a really
crappy 2015 documentary with like this
uh uh this Canary coat wearing really
fat American Midwestern pastor of some
sort saying you know the Bible is the
literal truth every word and he's
standing next to the the Israeli guy
with the omicon
um who's uh the head of the archeology
of it he's just sort of like sitting
there and awkwardly nodding
um as uh they talk about the uh of the
digs but they found this amazing stuff
including recently
um or semi recently
um sealed Scrolls that they only
unsealed now
um that reference the names
um as they were um uh talking about in
the Bible there's a story about Jeremiah
who they threw in a well because he was
a pain in the ass or something
um and uh and in the in the uh in the
Old Testament they say that this person
son of that person and also this person
some of that person were the ones who
like accompanying him to the cistern and
um when they found these sealed things
and they unsealed them and on on the
stone tablet it was the same this person
son of that person
um like with the orders to it's crazy
right um it's just kind of crazy and
blows your mind and I'd never heard of
it before and it's really interesting I
recommend go checking out the city of
David
um Museum archaeological uh dig
um lots of stuff in Israel is very
interesting in Jerusalem in particular
uh but this will uh if you're as
ignorant as me which is hard to do you
have to work at it
um uh it will uh it'll pop open your
eyes and it doesn't immediately come to
mind as much as some of the other
classical places to look at
a men people all right we're going to
have a webathon next week again please
send us your emails uh ask us anything
at Roundtable at reason.com and get
ready to loosen up all of that extra
FTX stock or whatever
um no please don't we don't want that
okay I thought it was like bargain now
or I don't understand how anything Works
um but we'll be talking about that a lot
more on uh next Monday's episode and
we'll be taping in the middle of the
week
um on Wednesday on the uh bonus ask us
anything
um so just get ready for all that stuff
you can follow all of our podcasts at
reason.com podcasts including the recent
interview with Nick Gillespie and also
his Speakeasy uh series uh Nick is there
any speaking easily that you're doing in
the near future that you want to talk
about there's uh one coming up in New
York on Thursday December 1st uh with
Caitlin Bailey who runs a sex worker
activist group that seeks to
destigmatize and decriminalize sex work
called Old Pros online go to reason.com
events and you can get information and
buy tickets ten dollars get you into the
event which includes beer wine soda and
food as well as stimulating conversation
great all right we'll see you next week
thank you for listening and get ready
for exciting fundraising
all right
[Music]